déjà au début de la marche
l'ambiance était tendue des milliers
d'albertains est rassemblé pour le
climat se sont heurtés à d'autres
manifestants cela propre et roll ils
désirent eux aussi se faire entendre
radieuse il m'insulte dit ce manifestant
autochtone alors qu'on essaie de trouver
une solution pour le climat et soutenir
une jeune fille qui a de bonnes idées il
la voilà cette jeune fille qui fait
courir les foules très tactile berg
entouré par d'autres jeunes qui tente de
la protéger
toute la famille de sam a fait trois
heures de route en covoiturage pour la
voir inka grings
victoria à 16 le même âge que greta et
d'autres jeunes comme cali 12 ans dont
le père travaille dans le secteur
pétrolier sont moins convaincus le
premier ministre albertain le
conservateur du g5 qu'eni était loin de
la scène occupée a inauguré un gazoduc
au centre ville d edmonton pendant qu'un
convoi de camionneurs pro pétrole se
fait entendre
les marcheurs pour le climat arrive
finalement au pied de l'assemblée
législative pour écouter le discours
tant attendu et si l'un de vos soucis
sont menées via people and indeed
ghadjati des nda duo et quad attaques
spécifiques contre l'industrie
pétrolière mais on appelle à des
changements profonds et à la
réconciliation
mais les événements d'aujourd'hui nous
rappelle que la réconciliation pourrait
être difficile en alberta une province
au coeur des débats climatique ici
laurence parfait radio canada est le
menteur